hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to answer a question from one of
my readers Miriam who is a face book
reader who asks a question dear Evan
many thanks for the videos that you put
up is really inspiring and full of
wisdom I love them a lot but I have a
question to ask is all you serve for
free so thank you Mary for the great
question and I'm glad you liked the
video that's great it's what makes me
want to do more of these for you guys
most of the videos that I do are for
free I try to do video a day don't
always accomplish that but I try to get
a video coming out every day and I
started doing the videos because people
are asking me questions and I would
usually write detailed email responses
back to them and I thought I could help
more people by creating the video it
helps that person and it also helps
everybody else who might have the same
question so I thought it was an
opportunity to help more people than
just the one on one that I was doing
before and I've always been a visual
learner so I like watching videos myself
that related to business so I thought I
could help a lot more people learn that
way as well now some of the videos that
we do are supported by some of our
sponsors we work with some brands like
Telus and american express and they will
sponsor some of the videos I may mention
them somewhere in the video or on the
description go ahead for the most part
most of these videos especially the ask
Kevin videos like this I don't get paid
to do their free videos sometimes you
may see a couple ads that YouTube puts
on there but those do not pay very well
let me tell you so it's just something I
love doing I filmed these once a week on
a Wednesday morning and it's always one
of my favorite days of the week because
I know I can can come down to my
basement studio and just film away and I
know gonna be helping a lot of
entrepreneurs so takes your question
again know most of the stuff is not paid
there's no word from your model behind
it it's just following my passion doing
what I love doing and hopefully helping
a lot of entrepreneurs in the process
hope that helped answer your question
Miriam for those will be watching if you
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up below
again I do this because I love doing it
and I always loved seeing those thumbs
ups makes me want to keep doing these
videos for you guys it helps let me know
that you enjoy them and if you have a
question or comment I'd love to hear
from you about you know the same topic
around the videos or brand new question
about your business I'd love to try to
help you out if you want to leave a
comment under this video so thank you
and you'll see you on the next episode
you